[Music]
1989 november the fml energies the
guerrilla that then became a political
party in el salvador launched their
final offensive which was called
offensive inaudib because that was their
final push to take the capital
an intense urban fighting came into
place
around san salvador and they took hotels
one of the hotels they took they didn't
realize at the time that a high
commissioner of the u.n was held captive
there
and they fought with marines u.s marines
for
a long period of time up until they
realized that
they messed up with somebody who wasn't
supposed to be there and they released
him and they they let the gorillas go
away and that was the turning point
on that specific attack and then
negotiations took place for
several peace agreements in this hotel
that we are standing here so this is
somewhat an iconic place
san salvador is full of history
bloody history
[Music]
so there was this one congressman
francisco marino and he has this
incident with the police where he was
drunk driving and he shot a policewoman
and this was a huge scandal he's
as you would imagine his picture
appeared in all the newspapers he was
from a small party that was like a like
a swing party that they decided uh and
back then the assembly was
right-wing arena
related to the dead squads in the in the
war and guerrilla fmln because you
cannot really arrest a
congressman he's taken to a sort of
impeachment trial
and in that process
arena says okay we're gonna
not impeach your congressman but you're
going to give us the votes for
legalization it was not a matter of if
this is convenient for the people if
this is what the people want but it was
a matter of do you have the votes and
how can you get the boats because it is
something that the elites want
in that moment we have nafta
but the opposition was
in that time fmln
for mercurial and you know like
imperialism yankee intervention
privatization
of the banks
the
communications and the electricity
companies everything so that happened
hand-in-hand with the dollarization yes
it was in 2001.
many call centers arrived to the country
and i'm a italian speaker so i got a job
in an italian account and i got a very
good salary so for me it was good to
have the dollar for the regular people
was very bad
sometimes it feels like you don't have
another option
if you leave a call center
you will not find another job or there
will be nothing else that you can do
with uh with i mean
where can i get money so how i'm going
to survive
there was not technical debate that was
on the basis of the approval of the law
the people did not have immediately
clear
how and why would we benefit of changing
our currency to the dollar we were like
trapped into devoid of polarization and
savage
neoliberalism you know since that moment
there was essentially a rug pool
that was financed by the lower income
classes there's no loans unless you have
land
so
our experience is that
we we've had to continue working but as
a collateral we've been losing property
after property
the dollar increase
prices
increase
payments for rent so i consider it a
decrease the quality of life of the
average population here in the country
for example you could get a
pound of tomatoes for five colonies
one dollar it's equal to 8.75
colonies
so since that moment you are not paying
five colonies but you are paying a
dollar
i'm sure inflation
slowed down a couple of points i'm sure
colonists would now be a lot
more worthless than they
were back then
as a struggle in society it increased
violence it increased the lack of
opportunities for people
my neighbors all of them move away to
the united states
the friends i made from childhood all of
them moved
not having
a salary
or even a formal job you know we have
almost
80 percent of informal uh commerce here
in the country so not everyone has like
the chance or even having a bank account
in the country so
the gap between rich and poor increased
since the dollar
got here in the country
[Music]
we were
at the midpoint of being governed or
ruled by a right-wing policy that
implemented all the new liberal policies
existed like
directly from ims directly from
the canadian school directly from
whatever the multilaterals wanted in
hindsight they were in cahoots with one
another and co-governing they saw
homicide rights go up they saw
economical rates never take off
immigration kept surging towards the usa
it was like war i actually was thinking
fearing war and nobody has declared but
so many people design
people have been lied to stolen from
thrown in jail for nonsense for 30 years
in comes this
savvy politician who
is a mastermind social media who had
been part of fmln and knew them as a
whole but also was seen as a
challenging young breville kind of guy
in their family for us it's all about
modernizing the country regardless if
you agree or not with the government we
need to do this for el salvador it
doesn't matter what what type of
ideology you have and then he ran on the
presidential race his most favorite
slogan is
which is there's enough money if people
don't steal it it's really about pushing
our country forward so we can
we can go into into the future and make
a better country for the new generations
he won a landslide election and he again
won a landslide election to control the
majority of the congress and up to that
point so far so good there have been
reforms and now it seems that the
judicial branch is favorable to the
asidas party so
i don't
there's there's been a lot of hura in
western press
about this being a coup or some kind of
undemocratic effort and you know the
facts don't lie if you put in the work
to find out how this all played out and
so unless someone can prove to me that
they stole the election somehow
they won fair and square and they are
following their constitution political
opposition to president lacks legitimacy
because both the right-wing party arena
and the left-wing party fmln were really
corrupt this is the will of the people
and
he is dearly loved and and and approved
of by most people
i was six years
in congress
and then i run for president the first
time the political party was arena
and
i didn't finish the campaign
i saw too much corruption
[Music]
we want el salvador to become the next
singapore absolutely and it's not just
an idea that president bukele has shared
you know even publicly i mean you can
read it once in a while
on twitter he just tweets singapore and
that's it
he's saying a lot with that and for us
who in my case i work in tech
investments and i understand that
anything and everything educational
health water everything relates to
technology and if we modernize the
country and are able to bring investment
the necessary investment in order to
make it run in a more efficient way then
yes absolutely we will become the next
singapore at least in the latin american
region and i can tell you that is the
goal yes
everything started here
el sante is like a small village a
surfing town a fisherman town
the first tourists that came here were
surfers
surfing changed her life here have been
always
part of our history of life
when we started
using bitcoin our social project
bitcoin beach hosante started to be in
the focus of many people all around the
world
many people that
hear
that in this little town
these guys
this group of young people
start to
create in the first
circle
economy all around the world based on
bitcoin
i have been witness yes there's still
crime at the center we cannot deny it
yes there's still
garbage thrown away
but not as much as it were a couple of
years ago
we came working from more than 10 years
ago
with this big dream to change her
community to and how we're gonna change
our community giving tools to the young
people that they can start to fight for
their dreams here and stop dreaming to
go to the united states and working
there
the government realized that this was a
way
to implement these main ideas of
values and freedom and and
inclusion and
and prevention of violence and education
and how this can be
recreated elsewhere
and i think that's what we inherited
from the hosante program
this dream
started here in sante we never chance
that our project
will inspire a nation
but that can become as a legal tender
[Music]
the first time i heard about this was
um
from a conference in miami beach
from a white guy who says that
now he and he's introducing the
president of my country and says this is
going to be your legal tender president
duques was running as a candidate for
the presidential election a lot of
proposals if you will
were given to the population and there's
actually a digital agenda on the
president's website that anybody can
have access to it's also in english and
they can see the pillars in which we are
focusing on as a country
however
bitcoin was not included in that digital
agenda in 2019 however we saw the need
to
adopt anything that could take us faster
in a more
consistent way into the future
so the logical thing to do was to move
forward and adopt the most
uh
famous well-known and in this case
secure coin and that was bitcoin it was
a no-brainer
[Music]
in short sweet terms it made bitcoin
legal tender in the salvador
period
with all of the legal implications
that that has
i would say that when bitcoin law uh
came down
this was
kind of a repetition of the
terrorization bill but it's faster
bitcoin law was announced on a sunday
and on wednesday it was approved as a
legal tender in new zealand and you
could probably say a lot of the same
technical
critics that you say to the organization
you could also just translate 20 years
in the future
and say the same about bitcoin
it was like a pretty cool decision so it
was a surprise a surprising thing for
everyone in the country and even for
bitcoiners
of the country the legal community but
us they thought that this was
full gold
that was being introduced into the
economic system
so
i think it's like a battle
you know between education and no
education and an open-minded idea
for people let them know what can they
do with a tool that could like
give us freedom
the risk here is to be free so i
consider people doesn't know about the
benefits of being free because they
always been
like uh i don't know
what day government sets or other sets
you know but it's time for us to get
personal sovereignty and decided about a
real freedom
[Music]
president buckley's
immensely popular like hitting 80
charts and approval rates
and bitcoin was the first unpopular move
that he made
what is the long term
effect that this is going to have right
this decision
made for us is gonna have and i think
that the most part of the fear that it
that we have
as a population is that
when we got dollarized
it was the same speech about like having
two
legal currencies
but
it went
um the the colon went
out of circulation because
we don't know why
we have been going to this rural places
in this small towns outside of the
capital outside of san salvador and the
salvadorian perspective it's been a very
political perspective
so um people in the
um oh honestly all around the country
but most part in the rural um
zones in the country that they don't
know a thing about bitcoin they just
think that this is a bucket list coin or
or this is similar to a dollar or they
think that the dollar is going to
disappear after this that's all they
have heard from the television from the
news
[Music]
like in any democracy i think opposition
is healthy i actually think they will
they will be there in any country and
they should be there in order to balance
power but at the same time it's
interesting to see that people who are
against the president or who are against
the government are also against bitcoin
just because you need to be against you
know anything that the government does
and that's a huge mistake because
they're not really informing themselves
or educating themselves in regards to
what bitcoin can do for them in regards
to gaining not only financial freedom
but at the same time allowing them to
save and to invest in another medium
that is the future so yes there were
people who were against it there were
organizations who were against it but at
the end of the day we knew that this was
the right thing to do the government had
a big issue even with the bitcoin
community on the article 7 of the law
which says it's mandatory
that's not being really implemented so
the government is not enforcing that
part of the law and so that's made
people kind of like okay it's not gonna
affect me i don't have to buy into it
[Music]
i went out to the park to do some
exercise
it was a sunday normally on a sunday
there was almost nobody there
but there were some people there and i
remember oh there was a protesters going
to eat today
there were four types of people on that
protest
it was
some rich people who comes in big bands
in big cars you know there's been
another inflation
with the bitcoins you can ask people
tell me a bit about that
i believe that
since the bitcoin was
adopted as a legal
currency i believe that
prices went around 40 to 50 percent
inflation and probably it will come to
more
everything if you go to the grocery you
your groceries if you go
to a restaurant
they have
a few percentage around 40 and 50
percent
they're not gonna tell you
the owners of the restaurants
but if you know the prices and you
go again and you see the prices with the
bitcoins it came out everything
has come up if you go to the
to where people buy their groceries not
the supermarket it's like a
central area where you buy uh you know
less than the grocery
people are gonna tell you
that they got a little percentage more
because they don't know what's gonna
happen with bitcoin if it's gonna go up
gonna go down
if it's gonna be stable or not
the bitcoin is it's
it's like this i mean it's not
every second it's moving you know you
have seen the application it's moving
every second but they made this because
they don't have any choice they don't
have more dollars
so they're gonna run out of money and
that's why they got their plan b is a
bitcoin you said there were four types
yes rich people rich people
very very poor people who came from
other
far away places from the country very
clearly you can see on the streets when
you if you if you went to the protest it
wasn't about bitcoin the anti-bitcoin
idea was just the one flag that they
could raise that somehow got more people
to show up there were many concerns
being expressed by people uh out in in
the protest but that was like the one
thing that they could cling on to
journalists bitcoin plays into the grand
scheme of things because it allows him
to have positive attention
of the world and presents himself as
this cool savvy president politician to
the world when he internationally and
nationally he has been
critiqued and questioned over these
authoritarian tendencies and
young people like me who is really
convinced are convinced that bitcoin is
a bad thing for the country
so for me
uh the last the last
type of people that are that i describe
this are the royal protesters
they actually think that
is a bad thing
that there is corruption and they go in
the government
and when i saw in the media
big protests in el salvador i was like
that's not real
i mean salvadorians don't fully support
bitcoin like knowing what it is and it's
going to be the best thing for a country
we're not like that
but also we don't oppose to it if you're
against the government you will see you
will be against bitcoin without even
like
getting to know really what it is there
is a very vocal and luciferous
opposition but they keep painting
themselves into a corner where they
could have understood that bitcoin was
their greatest ally and yet for whatever
reason they've chosen to cancel
themselves out of bitcoin at least for
the first semester we'll see how next
year plays out
take people from zero to one
we're teaching a basic stuff basic
concepts about bitcoin and try to guide
them on how to use wallets for example
how to identify different concepts from
bitcoin like centralized or
decentralized we're talking about
wallets in general in in what's a
non-custodial wallet or what is a
custodial wallet we changed the
mindset about money about what people
are used to be how we grew up thinking
that monies
is uh something that you can touch
and
to
explain that to people that they never
have access to the bank account they
never have access to the credit card to
the debit card to start to understanding
what is digital money and just jump into
the
bitcoin
is
[Music]
it's exciting
it's exciting but it took time and there
are some people that get it
they understand it
in the beginning
and their life have been changing
[Music]
we won't be able to dream about becoming
the next singapore if we do not push for
education providing the necessary space
for more programmers and developers
because those are really the careers of
the future at the same time right now
that bitcoin is legal
allowing
people on the street you know the
regular citizen who sells
uh gum or candies on the street to teach
them how to use the chibo wallet or any
other wallet it doesn't matter as long
as they use bitcoin but the key will be
in not just the government but also
academia and the private sector to unite
in order to do this
the first student that i got he's a uber
driver and actually
after
i think that it was the second class
he got a at least a general idea how
received bitcoin how transactions work
on change and on lighting
and
he says well
now that we are we are getting a lot of
people from other countries
they are going to get interesting if
they can make a payment in bitcoin and
he did a
a fair amount of shots on his trips and
i i met him the the past week and asked
him hey be honest
what do you do with those thoughts and
he said hey i'm holding we start to see
how we can use it in the social
initiative
and paying the english classes with
bitcoin paying the
young people to clean it no paying but
giving them like a bonus you know that
they can use it in the purpose area they
can use it to buy internet to be able to
to do their homeworks you know
and
some families had also like a problem to
find like a jobs and we started offering
like jobs and paying with bitcoin
this was the beginning of this
big move-in that now we all know
and everyone know about bitcoin beach
i didn't have to know how to program we
just have to do small tasks
and i was able to do it whenever i
wanted and they had the option to pay
through
paypal or bitcoin
so at the beginning i started asking
premier through python with the logic
inconveniences
of anti-money laundering regulations
being as strong as they are in a country
as violent as el salvador we are passed
through country from colombia and south
america to the us which means that the
narcos use us as an intermediate point
and this is something that has made the
u.s government and other international
government agencies
to force and salvort to implement
huge
anti-money laundering regulations i used
to hold it
and they paid me each week
when i had a big amount i used to bring
it to the country because paypal is
banned from the country you cannot bring
money
if you have it in paypal i used to send
it from my paypal account to a friend of
mine and he used to send it to me
through western union
on that
doing that i used to lose 20 of my of my
money so it was really hard for me but
that was the only way i had
my bank accounts are being closed i am
being investigated by the
fiscalia
because they
i have been
doing irregular transactions coming from
anywhere in the world to my bank account
now with bitcoin they deposit deposit it
directly to my wallet i don't lose
almost anything
[Music]
for most people
bitcoin is
still only a governmental subsidy
something that
you open up an app in a cell phone and
it allowed you to have 30 dollars to use
in something a friend
of mine yes me can you do us a drawing
can you make a drawing of us
when she was going to pay me she was
like i can deposit your bank account
because she was in samuel i was here in
san salvador it was a saturday night and
she said on monday i will wake up early
and i will go to the bank
i will be careful because of it i don't
like waking up early but i will have to
go i will deposit your money and i was
like you can just send me
the payment through bitcoin
and she was like uh really
and
it was a matter of some minutes i mean
in a matter of minutes i had the money
in my wallet
she said oh my god that's a relief i
didn't know it was that fast
i have received several payments through
that way was this after the 30 dollars
from chivo yes
being a legal tender now
allows us to easily convert
from us dollar to for any fiat
currency to bitcoin and vice versa it's
seamless
it's delightful in the sense that as a
as a small business person
i am able to reduce operating costs
financial costs from having to go
through
the usual suspects or her or their
financial institutions here in salvador
we don't we don't really use unchanged
that much because the fees are very high
and uh we're making a lot of
transactions per day so we prefer to use
the lightning network because it's um
it's faster and it's easier and no fees
in the most most of the cases or fees
are very low we had the espresso bar
everybody that came at least 80 percent
of
individuals
particularly
requested lightning network to make
their transactions
so i was happy to also learn about the
various wallets out there and the pros
and the cons
it was a pleasant experience so it
wasn't as hard as one imagines the first
patient i had pain in bitcoin was a 64
year old person
that it's a construction worker
he doesn't know how to read but he has
some lightning wall you know so he had a
previously education in the use of
aligned wallet
the value of money
[Music]
our crowdfunding bitcoin is miles we
have currently
1.8 bitcoin to work and provide critical
dental care for the impoverished
communities so bitcoin fixes teeth as
well
when bitcoin come to our community we
started to see people saving money for
the first time
people
buying like an asset for the first time
small merchants transacting digitally
accepting payment making digitally
payment for the first time
for many people this is sounds like
not like a big issues right because
you don't see the problem if you don't
live in the problems but for
people from
europe from the united states from
canada maybe when they go to the coffee
shop and they order a coffee is is
normal to get like a debit card credit
card and pay digitally but that's a
loser that not everyone have all around
the world
that bitcoin have been representing that
for this side of the world you know
giving access to our population
seventy percent of our
population in osaka didn't have access
to the financial system to the actual
financial system but
now
more than four million people in your
salvator have access
to the new financial system
they can receive their remittance in
in their wallets
without someone that say
no you cannot do it
we all can use it in different ways and
every human people can benefit from that
it's just understanding what bitcoin
representing for you
for us have been representing access to
the financial system
for the majority of the people they see
bitcoin just like an asset but people
need to understand also that bitcoin is
a monetary network this concept
is
for people to understand it's like
bitcoin is going to be like internet
bitcoin is going to be in the center
our purpose is to establish a genuine
direct trade relationships with our
final consumers as we're roasting here
at origin and exporting directly to
customers who are willing to pay via
lightning network eliminating financial
institution high commission and other
transaction costs associated with banks
down here
the satoshi blend is an idea of
financial freedom we chose the sampacho
varietal of our arabica harvest as well
as the red burban because of the quality
and because of the association and
meaning it has related to the coffee
rust disease that impacted coffee
producer countries a decade ago
we call it green bean or gold
this is our goal this is our bitcoin
[Laughter]
[Music]
the grid matrix that we have allows us
to take advantage of the geothermal
power alternative to the petroleum oil
bunker oil fuel so here where we are
now near guatemala we're about one
kilometer north of la hill they have a
headquarters here in awa japan also and
as you drive you can see all the all the
gas coming out of the
the mountains and the volcanoes so all
that and will enable us also to maybe in
the future have another
cluster of
bitcoin mining activity
the date the video of president bukele
during the bitcoin
2021 conference uh was broadcasted he
went on a twitter space
along with many other people right so we
all followed him he was asked
so what do you think about mining is el
salvador going to mine bitcoin
and right at that time just out of the
blue and i'm saying it wasn't something
that had been planned ahead of time
he
he said well we have plenty of volcanoes
in fact we have 23 volcanoes in el
salvador and he said i think we should
we should mine with our volcano energy
and it blew everybody's minds because we
hadn't even thought about it honestly it
shows you two things one how something
that perhaps had not been thought of
around the world can be done in a
country like el salvador one of the
tiniest countries in all of latin
america and two how we also have a
leader who's not only a millennial but
an innovator
and
we have a mining plant in berlin
and it's a it's utilizing geothermal
energy the plant is surrounded by
volcanoes and it's just incredible that
we're actually doing this but at the
same time that we're also getting
support from other companies
it's great that they will have more
investment in new energy infrastructure
they need to have more energy to produce
and been developed and available in
salvador from salvadorian sources
there's a lot of opportunity and i hope
that salvador becomes the you know
pioneer and world leader of geothermal
energy my understanding is that
geothermal in el salvador for it to go
to mining would need to be new
geothermal and we need to know more
about the lead times there
[Music]
if a person from another country tell
you
hey what do you what is your opinion on
bitcoin or what do you think of bitcoin
salvador is going to give you an honest
answer i don't know i don't understand
but if you if you say do you want to
you know maybe i will share some
knowledge of bitcoin with you they're
gonna
maybe i'm excited but i
i fully sure that and 99
of salvatore is going to say yeah
let's talk about bitcoin
and even if they don't accept bitcoin
they're going to say
yeah let's talk about bitcoin and they
really appreciate that you are sharing
with it with them knowledge if you meet
someone that's anti-bitcoin and el
salvador please be patient and listen to
their arguments because you will realize
that they're just confused and they just
need someone to help guide them along
their orange peel journey
i see many tourists that when they come
here they sit with the locals in talking
and it's
really exciting
seeing
tourism changing their mindset about
bitcoin
and the locals also
have their there is more options to
learn from there
because
in places like el salvador or latin
america we grew up thinking that
the bad things are in europe the bad
things are in canada in the united
states
but
when people come here and they're super
exciting and they're like wow this is a
big dream but it's like a big dream of
everyone
seeing tourism
changing their mindset and saying like
well
before
i came to el salvador i didn't want to
spend my thoughts my bitcoin once i'm
here
i'm more willing to do it
to help people
because bitcoin representing that
bitcoin representing
that chance
to make
this place a better place for this
generation but also for the next
generation that are coming
the government cannot educate
its entire population on bitcoin or on
any other related topic
we need help and
we have to do it hand-in-hand with the
academia with companies meaning the
private sector and investors from the
outside or companies who have started
arriving into el salvador opening
offices and recruiting staff and i've
been seeing it because i've been on
boarding many of these companies so if
we all work together the experience the
bitcoin experiment in el salvador is
going to be a success and we all want it
to be a success because if it works out
here in a country that has a population
of 6.5 million it's going to work out
anywhere we just need to keep on pushing
and educating our population
[Music]
we believe that hyperbiconization is the
most important race
of the 21st century
and for whatever reason central america
has a unique
situation where we are perfectly poised
to win that race we think it's the only
race that will matter in the 21st
century so everything we can do to
increase the odds of central america
winning that race we are here to do
[Music]
is one of the
departments the 14 departments that make
up el salvador and when the announcement
was made last saturday by the president
of bitcoin city to reactivate the
economic activity in the east for all of
us we were very happy because it's
progress for the country that means less
people are going to have to migrate to
the city it's going to decentralize
bitcoin city is going to be built
very close to samuel where i was born
it's cultural context
what does it mean for el salvadorian
what does it mean that this bitcoin city
is going to be built in london and not
in the center of the country
historically those cities has been
abandoned or in the oblivion because
through all our history in el salvador
every development every improvement has
been in the capital city it will give
opportunities to the people who live
there and they will not have to move to
leave their families
for a government
that has a deficit in its budget
it needs to get new liquidity from
creditors
traditional creditors
the
lender of last resort the imf
is the only one on the table right now
for el salvador
for the traditional fiat
blending to see if el salvador can
extend beyond the 100 percent that gdp
to you know united states levels of 130
that the gdp but in order to do that
obviously there are some
considerable strings attached and i try
to put myself in
their shoes if your party is known as
nuevas ideas
literally new ideas
and in order to finance them the one
person that shows up at the table is the
lender of last resort and their
financing comes with all of these
strings
essentially you're being asked to go
from the party of new ideas
to call yourself the party of new ideas
but financing the same old ideas
so
i can understand perfectly why they have
chosen to stick their middle finger in
the in front of the imf
but i don't even know if it's just that
i think they are playing them i think
what they realize is that their bitcoin
at this point has matured to the point
where there's another player that they
can sit down at the table with and
that's bitcoin
it seems that in this iteration it's
blockstream and bitfinex and great for
them i think what they are demonstrating
is that nation states that are facing a
similar situation to what a salon is
facing with fiat in the petrodollar
system have another
option have a lifeboat a life raft that
they can grab onto
the same way that many individuals that
have found bitcoin have seen bitcoin as
a life ref so
i believe that they're still negotiating
with the imf
there's still a possibility that the imf
gives them provide some sort of
financing but for this new financing
is it different it can be we'll have to
look at the details in the bond you know
how how is it structured what are the
rules like what is an investor actually
buying but it would seem that through
liquid the side chain where these bonds
are going to be
available
almost anyone in the world is going to
be able to buy these in small amounts as
well so it's a brave new world really
for
for financing states
that
are leading their people in the
direction that
other creditors are willing to support
so
as long as the government uses those
proceeds
well
and so the conditions that i saw was 50
for the purchase of bitcoin for custody
i'd love to see the details on who's
custodying you know how is that
both isaac going to work it would be
very good to know but then the remaining
500 million is supposed to be invested
in salvadorian energy and other kinds of
infrastructure to lay the groundwork for
a bitcoin city so
if
we do not see
results
from those investments so this is the
case every every pla every country on
the planet of all this financing that
comes from the traditional fiat
petrodollar and it's like oh yeah they
paid 100 million dollars for a port that
never showed up so
um if now you're relying on a creditor
that has
the ability to
you know take their money off the table
and not seen as a as a creditor of last
resort
then they have to keep our interests
right
we'll see if
uh bitcoiners actually play play it like
that way and and if there is corruption
if they are stealing the money will
bitcoiners no longer buy the bots right
that'll will have to verify and for now
my my message would be just don't trust
verify
salvadorian i feel really proud to be in
the middle
of the public eye
not for bad things
not for a wall
not for gangs not from violence not from
being the murder capital of the world
i will talk to my grandchildren that i
lived in this in this era of change
this is our version of the fall of the
wall of berlin
is the adoption of bitcoin and it's
gonna it's sending shockwaves
around the world
i consider that bitcoin it's a tool that
it's going to
change humanity the change we are living
in and it's going to provide hope
in our case our country suffers too much
and it's time to stop suffering it's
time to believe in ourselves it's the
time for take action
[Music]
we need the most help
from everywhere in the world of people
that really understand are into bitcoin
and really understand the benefits and
if they have a way to um
provide something and help us as a
community to grow
el salvador
is making history
he's leading this new revolution it's
leading this new dream this new
freedom
i have 25 years old and i never get
any kind of interest in politics i mean
i hear my father
i hear my uncles even so my grandfathers
hear about politics
and things like that
but i never
never seen on my give days on my john's
days anything that politics really do
and generate an impact here on the
saddle and
you know what happens that we we came we
came out from a civil conflict it's not
not too too much time has passed after
that and
i think that the goons
was still fresh a couple of decades ago
and that is the main reason that
politics
never did something that generates an
impact and what happens now is that
president obukhela came and actually
begins to see things
that
a lot of people see you know
as example
if you ask me the previous president
what does he do
that
benefits you or generate an impact in
your life my honest answer is going to
be i don't know
but
if my kids in the future ask me
what president nagi bouquet did in his
time that
makes an impact on your life
my answer is going to be
bitcoin hey
we come
from
being forced into adopting
political views political
ways of thinking
from both ends
from the communist and capitalists
that haven't done any good
for us as salvatorians
we have been forced either you're with
one side or with the other and i will
kill you if you do not agree with me and
that led to a civil war
and that led to coups and that led to be
us being one of the poorest economies in
the world and now with this i see it as
a game changer i i used to draw in my
art
dead people or violence
and now
and i realized that the el salvador was
exporting
feelings of death feelings very very
negative feelings because that's our
history that's what we live
but i don't want and just i want to to
stress that a lot i don't want to be
like that anymore that's that i can i
can tell that's the general feeling of
the population we don't want to be like
that anymore
we want to leave that in the past
the spirit of the country was lost the
spirit of the country was death and now
we can at least dream of something that
keeps us alive
that make us think maybe our
sons or daughters will not have to go to
the united states to live
maybe we will not have to say goodbye to
them anymore
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i would really challenge the question
that it's changing el salvador's lives
for people
uh it's
pr
and it's too soon for actually to be
changing the lives of millions of people
[Music]
you